NOT HAD A TON OF SCORING, AND
TYAND NOW, RAFFL IS ON THE
MOVE,  WELL.
SO THERE HE IS, RIGHT IN THEHE
TO LINDHOLM LOOK FOR THE TIPR
YEAR.
IT GOES AROUND FOR GAUDRDRNEARL
FROM A
AMERICAN-BORN SCORER HAS SCO
>> Meaghan: THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HE WORKS ON AFTER EVERY
AND WORKING ON WAYS TO ELEVATE.
>> Dave: THERE MAY NOT BT HIM,
OF THE WAY TS, AND THEY HAVE
HAD AMAZING CAREERS THE SAME
YEAR, AND IT WAS RIGHT AFTER
THEY HAD THE NATIONA KIV ISHGS
EVERYBODY ELSE WENT DOWN.
>> Dave: AND NOW, BENN TO THE D
IS GOING TO BRING IT HOME, AND
NOW, IT T  GLOVE GOES TO THE OUD
TO CALGARY FROM U WITH US.
CORNER AND SENT OVER T THE
DEFENSIVE ICE, IS GOING TO STAR
OFF, AND TYLER SEGUI ONE, AND
HANIFIN'S SHOT WAS KICKED BY HAS
ARE GOING TO COME AWAY WITH IT.
, AND BACK
TOROWN AWAY HIS CAREER HIGHS
>> THAT IS A BIG AND
WITH LINDELLE ICE.
F THE ZONE.
AN GUDBRANSON, AND THEHE GAME T.
THAT MAN JOE PAVELSKI HAS THE O
AND CALGARY WITH TWONFERENCE YE
VANCE TO THE STANLEY CUP TE
TOFFOLI, AND NOW, A OPENPPORT.
>> Meaghan: YOU HAVE TO THINK IT
IS THE SET